let's start with uh christine i believe
christine you had your hand very
patiently raised last time so let's
start with you
now a reminder we are we are recording
this session as i put the last one on
linkedin so this could happen again so
by participating you know that that
might happen not you know just kind of
our
our release form implicitly all right
christine go ahead
sounds good thanks for the great memory
and of course like everyone here big fan
been a user for quite some time uh my
question for you is
in times where you're trying to make a
decision where the answer isn't super
clear it's a really tough choice whether
this is deciding what major you want to
have in college when you want to stay in
a job or leave a job
what are values or a piece of advice
that you turn to making these type of
decisions
yeah that's a good that's a good
question i i do feel like that you know
this
decision making is one of these things
that no one really explicitly in any way
teaches you or gives you even frames of
reference i heard a quote recently which
i really liked and i do think it this is
part of my life philosophy i'd like to
believe which is
um
there there's often times no right
decision but you can make the decision
right
so
once once you've committed to a decision
i do think that it is um and my my mind
does tend to work this way
i tend to convince myself that i made
the best possible decision
and then i do what i can to make the
decision right
you know one first of all if you're
always second guessing the decision by
definition whatever decision you made
will almost you're making it wrong
because you're always looking at what
the alternative path could have been
so that's that's my first advice is
always have an attitude of making the
decision right no matter what you're
doing whether it's a job or a major or
choosing a partner just think day in day
out
what can i do today to make this make
things better to make a positive dent in
the universe to learn more to get
excited about it
when you're at the point of making a
decision
i i tend to
you know do my best to just um
uh
do a fairly rational decision tree if i
can uh not now i will say
and i do i do do do that uh you know
i've often joked that
people know me for my my math videos and
science videos and other videos but i've
also wanted to make like things like a
dating video like i i've i've met
friends who might be with someone and
i'm like why are you going to marry that
person and they're like well no probably
and i was like then why are you like
every day that you delay this you're
just making the pain larger in some
future future state and if you do the
decision tree it's not a complicated one
you're like
less pain now versus ignoring it and
making more pain in the future so i i do
recommend taking a lens of that
i also think making
making decisions that are not just in
your best interest
but making decisions that are that
you're truly trying to make it an
interest of anyone everyone involved in
the system you know i try not to judge
people but when i do judge people
i i i judge them on the decisions they
make
uh that
the consequences for them are
where they're looking at the
consequences of the system not just the
consequences for themselves um
i mean going back to the whole the whole
dating example i've seen people
i i'd say not to judge but sometimes
selfishly stay in something that lowers
the other person's option value over
time uh which which i think is actually
very very selfish that's the times i've
i've most harshly judged people although
i try not to judge you know
uh we we all we all we all have our
flaws
i i do think
that intuition intuition sometimes
we don't take it that seriously because
it kind of like oh you're just going off
of gut i do remind folks that your gut
actually does have a lot of neurons so
your gut is kind of a mini brain your
gut actually has more neurons than some
some animals have in their brains uh but
on top of that
we you know in our actual brains not
just even our gut brains we have hundred
billion neurons and
one of the critiques of machine learning
is that it can come up with insights but
you can't explain why that neural net is
coming saying that that is a dog and
that is not a dog i think our human
brains are similar is that it can it is
a big neural net and it can it what
intuition really is
is it's your neural net telling you this
is a dog and that's not a dog
but you can't exactly explain why of
course i can explain why something might
be a dog or not but um but why this is
the right major why this is the right
career why this might be the right
partner um sometimes i do think is is a
is a gut thing i i i've i've got to say
last time i talked about solving hard
problems and sometimes you just have to
look at the problem and engage with the
problem and then sleep on it and then
the next day all of a sudden you're
you've delegated to your subconscious
mind and it's been turning on that
problem while you're sleeping and then
when you wake up i found this sometimes
you can solve the problem almost
magically i found the same thing with
major decisions i don't fret too much
about them
i will i will think about them i will do
the whole decision tree thing
i'll oftentimes meditate to try to clear
my mind so i'm not thinking about the
decision
and it's interesting sometimes i'm
meditating i'm meditating and and the
answer just comes to me is just like
you've got to do this i was like oh of
course it's obvious or you sleep on it
for a night or two and then you just
wake up in the morning of course i've
got to do this this is the right thing
everything tells me that this the stars
are aligned here so there's no perfect
formula for decision making it's a great
question but that's my
the best the best wisdom that i have i
have and you know the more in life you
can
you can perceive the grass on your side
of the fence to be greener the more
happy you're going to be as a person and
i'm i'm i'm the king of that for better
for worse almost to a fault but but i'm
happy
all right let's see amit
ahmed a
uh hello assalamu alaikum everyone and
thank you so much sal for hosting this
uh i'm delighted to be here and it's an
honor to be here with all of you
aspiring learners my question is about
being content
i've struggled with this contest or
i've struggled with this concept a lot
i think that
people that they accomplish shouldn't be
content because being content
that limits them to a certain extent
what do you think about this do you
think that being content is just being
happy where you're at or is it being
happy along with
uh being or aspiring to be more than
where you're at
another very good very deep question
that i'm i'm i you know my life journey
i've i've had different frames of it i
think early early on in in in my life
when i was a lot of y'all's age i was
very not content i was i was i had that
proverbial fire in my belly i i i was
constantly thinking you know to
christine's last question how do i make
the right decision pick the right major
find the right job
i was afraid if i'm honest about well
what if what if i don't succeed what if
i
can't be
in a solid financial position many of
y'all know you know my family we didn't
my i was raised by a single mother we
didn't she worked a lot of minimum wage
jobs cashiers different places
eventually scrounged up enough you know
pennies to to open up a a not so
impressive convenience store so when i
was a lot of y'alls age i was just like
and and the good thing is we had a lot
of family friends who were professionals
who were doctors who were engineers and
i saw
how much better your life could be even
materially but to put aside what you do
in the hours of your work but even
materially you know my friends whose
parents were engineers had nice houses
in better neighborhoods they had health
insurance
their path was easier and so i had a lot
when i was a lot of y'all's age of angst
i i could only describe it as angst so
like
i can't i i need to get out of this i
need to get some so that was always a
bit of a burning motivation and i wasn't
content and when you're not content it
can sometimes i i wasn't overly angsty i
think i was a pretty if people knew me
they would say oh he's a pretty
happy-go-lucky laid-back guy but there
was a piece of me that i would sometimes
wake up in the middle of the night like
i can't i can't i can't mess this up you
know you have you know i was like quote
eminem you only got one shot you know
don't i forgot what he said in eight
mile but
it's it's always
um
but but the
there was some of that i think as i've
as i've grown older
uh especially i think in my in my 30s
i'm now 44 going on 45 uh but in my 30s
i started to realize that that that
angstiness and that a little bit of a
chip on your shoulder it's not maybe as
useful as you think it is uh it can
continue to make you once again
you're not enjoying the the ride as much
as you should
uh and and once again i did enjoy my
ride a lot i i had a lot of really great
memories from my journey but i think
it's i've started to appreciate more
that i should appreciate it in the
moment while it's happening
and be present and
there's this in in vedic philosophy uh
there's three aspects to everything in
the universe the one is a satwik which
means truthful uh you know you i'm i'm
maybe you speak words such you know
truth um and and
that uh and and and even in actions
there can be truthful action the second
aspect is rajasik for those who are
familiar with the the you know languages
from the indian subcontinent you can
think of raja like a king and and
rajasik is when you're very uh it's
considered a form of energy it's it's
when you're very uh focused on and
rejoicing action is when you're very
focused on the outcomes and then there's
thomasic the massive kind of like you're
not really in control it's a little bit
chaotic and you're doing something
because you're forced so satwik action
you're doing something because it's
right but you accept the outcome
whatever the outcome is it is what it is
you get new data points and then you
make a new set of decisions and do
what's right rajasik action or justice
decision making is to say
you know i'm going to do this because if
i do this i'm going to become rich and
famous and if i don't become rich and
famous i'm going to be really miserable
or i'm going to do this because if i
don't do this something really bad is
going to happen we're not going to have
enough money we're not going to have
food on the table we're not going to do
all that
and uh and and then thumasic is like i'm
forced to do it i don't really feel like
doing it but someone's you know whatever
i think we all agree that themasik is
not a good place to be for most most
things in your life rajasik is where
most of us are most of the time most of
us are saying hey if i do this
i'm going to get a promotion i'm going
to get a better job i'm going to do this
and
it can be very motivating and it can
give you the external
appearances of success
but it can also make you miserable and
and not content your entire life
because no matter what there's going to
be outcomes that that when you're in a
registered frame of mind you have
trouble accepting
i found that the more that i can move to
a kind of a southwick form of action
where i just do what is what i think is
right at any motion at any moment um
and then whatever the outcome is i can
just accept it and sometimes even enjoy
it or savor it and learn from it and
then take the next set of actions i
found that in no way does it does it
quelch my ability to do things or in no
way does it suppress my ability to take
action or to to be ambitious or try to
do big things but it makes me a lot more
content and a lot frankly a lot more
pleasant to be around
if i'm just accepting if i'm just
accepting things and i'll say a lot of
times i actually think you'll be more
productive if you take that satwik
aspect because a lot of times the the
justice aspect
your ego gets involved very very heavily
and so you know a lot a lot of times i
think we procrastinate because our ego
doesn't want to realize that it can't do
the thing and so it's like well oh maybe
let me go get a snack let me because
your ego is like protecting itself like
what if you start to study it and you
have trouble doing it or what if you
start to write that paper and you and
you have writer's block when you have a
subway point of mind you're like you
know what the right thing to do right
now is just to start the chips will fall
where they do
and so i find myself procrastinating a
lot less when i'm when i've gotten
less caught up with the outcome and i
just want to start taking action and
then i just accept the outcome wherever
wherever it is a lot of the stress at
work
has gone down dramatically i used to you
know sometimes i have some big decisions
to make uh that could affect a lot of
people
and when i take the regastic mindset i'm
like wow this is the wrong decision it
could affect these 10 people's lives you
know
it it can really stress you out it's not
going to help you make a better decision
you take a suffolk point of view let me
look at the data let me meditate on it
let me take the best possible decision i
can and look i just have to accept the
outcome and then let me make another
decision based on that but anyway i give
you a long-winded answer my apologies
but hopefully that that was useful
all right thank you so much
all right
um let's see
i don't know if i'm pronouncing your
name correctly
yeah you are um first of all
uh hi from india
it's actually um 12 45 a.m
thank you for staying up
yeah
i'm a huge fan and um i just wanted to
ask that you know we've always i'm a
college student currently and we've
always been um having so many like we've
been getting so many tips about you know
how to do uh smart work and hard work
and how there's a difference and i've
been using khan academy for a long time
and i just wanted to know how you would
differentiate between those two and if
you would have any um particular great
tips for us as we're making our ways
making our way through college and
building a resume
and you know
yeah well i think the different hard
work and smart work i i do think
i was fortunate throughout my entire
academic career that i kind of fell into
what would now be described as smart
work versus hard work
because when i was young i was the
student
that i i actually in my early years i
wasn't particularly grade motivated i
guess i was less for justice than i
realized i was actually more motivated
by hey this is interesting uh let me
connect the dots okay they're teaching
me this formula in this class but wait
that's kind of the same formula that we
learned in the other class if we just
change the variables or if you if you
just format the algebra a little bit
differently and when you approach any
knowledge that way
it naturally is going to connect more
it's naturally going to stick more
the more
you know i'm one of some of the things i
i really enjoy when i get covered in
khan academy or when other people are
covering it in khan academy is try to
connect the dots between different
things so they don't just feel like
things to to memorize
one you're going to learn it better and
life is just going to become is going to
become a lot more interesting
in the u.s
a lot of times they teach the louisiana
purchase some of y'all might know about
this you know in 1803 thomas jefferson
is able to buy louisiana from at the
time napoleon controlled france for like
3 million and louisiana was not just the
state of louisiana it was like a third
of what we now consider to be
the united states and the way they teach
it when i when i first learned that i
think in fifth or sixth grade was kind
of like they got a good deal
like you know that's how it's taught
like just memorize the fact 1803 they
bought louisiana and they got a good
deal
later i learned well the reason why they
got a good deal is that napoleon who was
trying to take over europe
had his navy defeated at trafalgar by
the british and so he really did not
have much of a navy to speak of and so
there's no way that he could protect
this territory that's on the other side
of the planet and so in some ways
napoleon got three million dollars that
probably the americans could have just
taken it and napoleon could have done
nothing about it and at least he got
three million dollars
more for it so you know that's just an
example of it's fun to connect these and
then when you when you connect it you
realize wow that's so interesting right
like these decisions that people are
making very human decisions
as opposed to just random random facts
in history
you know there's things that uh
in in hi there's things that in in
history or whatever you know in math
that will give you goosebumps if you
just look at them the right way so i try
to remind everyone sometimes you'll hear
me say this in khan academy videos you
know your biology textbook might seem a
little bit dry sometimes or hard to read
or your stats textbook but that biology
textbook like every chapter is the
culmination of probably a few hundred
people's life work like you know those
people would have done you know what
what isaac newton would have done to get
a hand get a hand get his hands on your
your calculus physics book or what um
you know
name them pasteur or curry would have
done to get their hands on your
chemistry textbook or to get your hands
on their on your biology textbook and
they really are explaining the universe
sometimes they're not doing it in the
most wondrous you know wonder provoking
way but they are fascinating things so
that's my my you know when you study
when you learn things just try to have
that that air of wonder and
when you watch a movie like harry potter
or something
we all get excited because we're like
wow they're finding out different spells
and they're looking at these ancient
runes and they're figuring out things
about the universe and and then they're
able to do magic and i view learning is
the same thing yes the books that you're
looking at are sometimes not the most
interesting thing but if you really
engage in it the way that hermione grand
granger would engage with it you're
going to see that you're going to be
able to do magic you're going to be able
to understand things about the universe
that frankly would have seemed like
magic even 500 years ago
and so when you view yourself as you're
this you're this person you're going on
this quest
there's things for you to explore
dots to connect
it just becomes a much more exciting
frankly experience uh and then when
you're doing that the whole time yes
i've sometimes found myself cramming and
having to but but even then
when you're cramming but the the
knowledge is being connected with other
things you're more likely to learn it
you're more likely to to to retain that
you know what my hermione granger uh
analogy reminds me of an answer to to
the pre the christine's question about
decision making
sometimes i do and this might be mildly
delusional i say look
you can view yourself as just kind of
living a mundane life or you could view
yourself as a protagonist in an epic
movie
and whenever you're faced with a hard
decision you're like well what would
what would the protagonist what would
bilbo baggins do in the hobbit what
would hermione or harry do in harry
potter what would
harry seldon do in in the foundation
series and i find that when you do that
first of all life becomes a little bit
more fun to live but you'll actually do
the more suffolk thing you'll do the
more like what would the protagonist do
in the story what will what would happen
here to make this a more interesting
story and it also reminds myself the
other way that no great story is not
with its it's
some significant stress you wouldn't
want to read any of these books or watch
any of these movies if they did not have
significant stress and moments of
tension and moments where you're not
sure how things are going to turn out so
when you have those significant stresses
or moments of tension or times that you
are unsure of yourself you're like oh
well i got a good movie that i'm living
like my movie is interesting uh but
that's that's that's my best best advice
stay curious
uh my advice on making decisions also
especially if you think about careers
and majors ask a ton of questions
people like giving advice as you see i'm
enjoying giving advice to you right now
people you know even in i try to
fundraise a lot and someone told me this
piece of advice which actually turned
out really true
if if you ask for money people will give
you advice if you ask for advice people
give you money
and it is somewhat true but the simple
but oftentimes the advice is the most
useful thing so
don't be afraid to ask as many questions
people who are a little bit older than
you who've gone through this
decision-making process uh you know get
them one-on-one and ask them some pride
you know what stresses you out um
if they're close to you and it's not
tacky ask them how much money they're
making ask them if they made the right
decision ask them how it's affecting
other impacts of their life their life
work balance and i think that's really
going to help you
make make make good decisions i was the
kid when i was in college i would
somewhat
i've never had a really strict filter
i've always said what i've thought and
and when i talk to people i've always
been willing to ask them pretty open
questions and i think if they realize
that you're coming from a place of
vulnerability yourself and authenticity
yourself people will also be vulnerable
and authentic with you and they'll give
you a lot of really good information and
advice
that is such a great outlook thank you
so much thank you
all right uh let's go to
vinay
oh hi son
i am in grade 10 and
first thank you so so much like for both
khan academy and schools like especially
for india i'm from india so we have the
cbsc great and board exam
so thank you so much like khan academy
really helped me a lot especially in
these exams
uh
like i'll just ask one question if you
were 18 right now or if you were at my
age what would you work on and why like
what do you think lies ahead in the
future for the youth
well i think it's gonna be a different
answer depending on what you're
interested in what you like but
but i do think the trending thing is
that artificial intelligence and the
most trending part of intelligence
computer engineering and all these
things
if you're interested in that
i i don't think you can go wrong with it
if you're interested in it i will say
you know i've often joked like i can
meet
i was a computer science electrical
engineering math major when i was in
college so i was doing the equivalent of
what you what you're thinking about uh
going forward but that's because i was
really interested in it when i went to
college i thought i wanted to be a
theoretical physicist i was fascinated
by theoretical physics i said like i
want to explain the nature of reality
and that's what physics is after i was
you know i'd read feynman's books and
look at his lectures and and i was
really inspired by that then i go to
college and i'm like even better than
studying realities creating your own
realities and i thought then that's what
i found was interesting about computing
is that software especially if you
thought about virtual reality and things
like you could actually create realities
uh and and so that's what what drew me
to that so if you have a passion for
that you have an interest for that
absolutely what i do recommend for
everyone here who's roughly 18 or so
years old is those subjects that you're
learning in your end of high school
early college really master them master
them as well as you can master them
because if you if you truly master your
high school early college level
calculus statistics biology chemistry
physics
maybe a little bit of econ if you truly
master it you're going to be unstoppable
in pretty much any field that you that
you want to go you're reading and you're
writing of course as well if you can
write well at that level you're going to
be unstoppable pretty much in any field
you can go i'll add communications
because i think a lot of the
schoolhouse.world tutors
they're building a muscle of
communication which is going to be
invaluable no one has grades on
communication there's no standardized
test scores on communication but the
reason why schools like mit and uchicago
are interested in schoolhouse.world
tutors is one it shows they know the
material but it also shows that they
know how to communicate fairly fairly
complex things
so that's my best advice and you'd be
surprised even today i meet a friend who
has a phd in biology they're working at
a biotech firm and they start explaining
their research and i can go surprisingly
far with them i'm like oh you're talking
about the krebs cycle oh that's
affecting atp production and they're
like how do you know this and i'm like
it's it's senior level biology or
freshman biology in college
and everyone learn everyone takes those
classes but most people cram take the
test and then forget it all but i will
tell you that those classes if you
really master it you're going to be
unstoppable and then of course you can
layer it on if you go into computer
science or artificial intelligence or or
whatever else
you know if i were to think about what
industries are really interesting
obviously artificial intelligence is
really interesting
i think biotech is going to be really
interesting with crispr i think you're
going to start seeing the intersection
of the two where
genetic engineering there's going to be
a lot of ethical questions around it but
there's going to be a lot of interesting
positive things that can happen for
humanity there as well
but anyway but even if you're not
interested in either those two if you
can speak well if you can write well if
you have a solid dose of analytical
skills
you will you will be uh very relevant uh
and and if you take
and i generally be if you're positive
and you you're authentic
and you're trying to do right by the
people around you and you surround
yourself with good people you're going
to do
just fine
thank you so much hope to meet you in
person in one day
yeah one day maybe it's disappointing
but yeah
all right let's see okay we have i could
go a little bit longer today and um i
will let's see matthew
thanks so much
this is matt i'm no longer a student
well i am a continuous student i love to
learn but i actually came to ask about
uh school outside world i was wondering
what you need to reach more people and
what your like pain points and blockers
are for growing the business
yeah i think um
you know what school schoolhouse
dot dot world is as you know the way
that we
the the the dream here the vision here
is that we eventually are able to make a
world where millions of people are able
to get uh free tutoring uh for for
everyone and the and i don't know they
keep spotlighting my video i actually
like seeing everybody else but anyway um
the the goal here is is to give uh a
free two-day make it for everyone right
now we're at a reasonable scale we have
several thousand people using
schoolhouse.world we have many hundreds
of amazing tutors i know many of y'all
are are some of them and i thank you for
that but our hope at the
schoolhouse.world team is to just
continue to scale it because i think
once we get to a scale that's maybe 10
times bigger than where schoolhouse that
world is right now then i think the
flywheel is there then i think
schoolhouse.world will only grow and
grow and grow and as you all might
appreciate the more tutors there are if
we have 500 tutors now if we can get to
5 000 tutors if we have 500 sessions a
week now if we go to 5 000 sessions a
week then pretty much anyone who shows
up there's probably going to be a
session on what they care about within
minutes or there might be a series a
group that they could join for multiple
weeks that's available
very soon
and so then you have high liquidity
i'm also hoping that and i've talked
about this last time that your ability
to become a tutor and be a highly
reputed tutor actually is gonna one
it'll feel good i think many of y'all
will enjoy doing that but above and
beyond that it has some cachet in the
broader world that it can connect you
with opportunity it can get you into
colleges it can get you a a job it can
get you a scholarship i i've talked to a
major scholarship group just day before
yesterday about exactly this about and
they are interested they are very
interested if you're a schoolhouse.world
tutor of wow these are exactly the types
of young people that we want to give the
scholarship to it's a significant
scholarship worth hundreds of thousands
of dollars
and i showed them and not to set
people's expectations too high i showed
them some of our highly ranked tutors
who are high school students and they
said wow
this is amazing these are exactly the
type of people that we wanna we wanna
work with so
um
i you know my hope is if we go five
years in the future
we have millions of people on
schoolhouse the quality is high the
amazing people who are giving tutors
many of whom who might have started as a
student trying to get tutoring are able
to get opportunities because they
clearly know the subject matter they can
they can they're trying to do good for
others uh and and they're clearly
articulate and can explain things uh
quite well so unfortunately i have
people calling me i realize i did i did
have
12 30 pacific time booked but i have
really enjoyed this sorry for the
long-winded answers i hope they can be
vaguely useful for y'all but i and i see
that i'm leaving about 30 uh hands
raised my apologies for that
what i will do is see if we can schedule
more of these because i enjoyed these as
well so
don't fret if this is if you're enjoying
this we will we will get a chance to do
this again so i will see you all then
talk to y'all later thanks for joining
and thanks for being part of the
schoolhouse community thanks so much
have a nice day
thank you
you